Speaker 1: We have a new controversy as we
continue learning more thanks to the January
6th Trump Riot Committee.
The new controversy involves Republican Congressman
Barry Loudermilk, who is now being accused
of having led a tour.
A reconnaissance tour for future would be
Trump rioters before January six.
Now, of course, he's denying it.
He says it was all on the up and up.
And he gave a bizarre interview to Fox News's
Laura Ingram, which we're going to look at
in a moment.
But first, let me catch you up on what it
is that is being alleged.
Barry Loudermilk says that the tour he gave
was not a reconnaissance tour for future rioters,
taking pictures of the security settings,
the security situation and tunnels and security
cameras, but rather it was people who just
wanted to take pictures of children's artwork.
That's what he says.
Now we'll see if we believe him.
Newsweek reporting Representative Barry Loudermilk
said a group he took through the Capitol complex
on January 5th were simply taking pictures
of artwork.
And he rejects the insinuation that he led
a reconnaissance tour on the eve of the insurrection.
On Wednesday, yesterday, the January six committee
wanted an explanation from him about surveillance
footage showing him taking a group through
the complex with a man seen photographing
security points and stairwells.
And the video is pretty weird.
The committee has shared footage purportedly
showing the same man who was taking the pictures
threatening top Democrats after the riots
on January six by supporters of ex-president
Trump.
Some Republicans were accused by Democrats
of giving tours to people who later went on
to storm the Capitol.
While the congressional committee has requested
a meeting with Loudermilk.
U.S. Capitol Police concluded there is no
evidence he led a tour with Trump supporters
trying to learn more about the complex.
On Monday, Capitol Police Chief Tom Manger.
Manger wrote in a letter, We do not consider
any of the activities we observed as suspicious.
Loudermilk told Fox News yesterday the conclusion
of the police doesn't fit the narrative.
The January six committee wants to come up
with it is a very strange coincidence, that
being said, that supposedly the person he
gave a tour to the day before the riot was
then seen rioting at the Capitol.
That is weird.
So let's go to the interview that Loudermilk
gave to Fox News host Laura Ingraham.
He says they were taking pictures of children's
artwork.
See if you think he is telling the truth.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, people who come to
Washington, D.C., like these people who have
never been there before.
Right.
They're excited.
They're taking.
Speaker 3: Pictures.
Is it against protocol or rules to take photos
in the lower level where they were?
Speaker 2: No, not anywhere except right around
the house chambers.
That's the only place that there's.
Speaker 3: So there's no restrictions in doing
this?
Speaker 2: No, absolutely not.
People take pictures there all the time.
Speaker 1: Now, in the video that they show
and I know that if you're listening, you won't
be able to see this.
It's certainly not evident that the things
that are being photographed are all, you know,
children's artwork and also is is children's
artwork that interesting, guys?
I mean, listen, I but I'm not at the point
in fatherhood where there's any artwork being
produced.
But I've been around lots of people whose
kids produce artwork, and it would never really
occur to me to photograph kids artwork.
And also, he initially said that he didn't
lead any tours anyway.
And then he said that he never heard from
the committee about answering questions when
they actually did contact him.
So he has told multiple lies.
And it's weird that people who the next day
show up at the riot are that interested in
children's artwork.
It just doesn't pass the sniff test for me.
Speaker 2: What does the January six committee
show the entire video?
Because they're taking pictures all up and
down the hallway when the guys near the tunnels
go into the Capitol, that's where they hang
the artwork that schoolchildren give.
And at the other end, there is the trolleys,
the trains, and the kids wanted to see the
trains that take the congressman to the House
chambers.
That's all this was.
And the Capitol Police, they know this.
Speaker 1: All right.
So that's his claim.
It's weird.
I mean, it's something about this doesn't
doesn't really make sense.
Let's go to the next clip.
Speaker 3: Sure.
But Loudermilk has to come and he has to testify
to clear this up.
Do you know anything about the guy taking
the photo?
And is is he some nefarious character?
Speaker 2: Not that I know of.
I mean, I did not know everybody that was
in the group as most members of Congress.
Speaker 3: When you go to testify, they say.
Speaker 2: They haven't asked me to.
Speaker 1: So that he says they haven't asked
him.
The reports are that he has been asked.
And so it appears that that's a lie.
Speaker 2: They keep asking you guys to have
me come.
They keep releasing this stuff to the media,
but they don't send me the letters.
Speaker 1: Okay.
As far as we know, that's not true.
The interview continues.
Speaker 3: You part of the ringleader in this?
Speaker 2: Exactly.
And what they're not showing is what was the
guy taking a picture of?
There is a golden eagle on the wall, right
upside that stairwell that's holding two candles.
Right.
That's why he's taking a picture.
People take pictures of that all the time.
Speaker 1: That's all it is, except in all
the footage this guy is taking pictures even
when they seem to be going through security
checkpoints.
And it's not obvious that there's I mean,
listen, if an eagle holding candles is that
compelling, if a if a kid's art piece of artwork
is that compelling, okay.
But there are videos where it's not clear
that there's any artwork on the wall.
He wonders why he is being targeted.
Speaker 2: But what the Capitol Police said
doesn't fit the narrative that the January
six committee wants to come up with.
Why they've targeted me, I don't know right
now.
Speaker 1: Of course, the reason he may be
targeted or the reason that he has raised
eyebrows is he initially said he didn't lead
a tour and then video of him leading a tour
came out and then he's claiming he hasn't
been asked to come testify except the committee
says no, we did ask him to come.
And then lastly, he says he will not change
his story.
A principled and defiant Barry Loudermilk.
He won't change his story because he must
stand for the truth, except he's already changed
his story.
The first story was I didn't lead a tour.
Now it's I did, but it was all fine.
Speaker 2: Guns, if there's pressure, I mean,
come on.
Speaker 3: I don't want.
Should you to to change your story about this?
Speaker 2: Oh, no, absolutely not.
And I won't, because there is a war on the
truth in this country now.
Speaker 1: And he's one of the people who
has been caught lying.
Speaker 2: We have to stand for the truth.
The easiest thing for me to do would just
been lay down and go dark.
I'm not going to do that.
We have to stand for truth and right if we're
going to if we're going to save this country.
Speaker 1: Right.
It depends.
The country's.
If he guys I mean, we can't he's been caught
lying multiple times.
That's why people are focusing on you.
Okay.
There were members of Congress who earlier
said, oh, yeah, I let it tour.
I let it tour here.
There.
Here's who showed up.
None of the people in the tour later showed
up at the riots.
This guy denied leading a tour.
Then the video came out.
One of the people who was on the tour ended
up at the Capitol on January six.
He's been caught in multiple lies.
He's changing his story already while simultaneously
saying, I will not change my story.
That's extraordinarily suspicious.
So let me know.
Do you believe him?
Do you?
I mean, it's it's something is weird about
his story, but maybe it rings true to you.
Let me know what you think